pour les plus jeunes
ceci est un dictionnaire c'est un peu
comme un vieux google sans youtube sans
facebook
bref c'est un gros bouquin oomu jeunes
les synonymes son candide crédules
inexpérimenté naïf au point où il en
était il aurait pu rajouter mou du genou
et sans avenir
ça fait longtemps que le dico a pas
croisé un jeune le problème c'est que la
société est restée figée sur cette
définition périmés
selon le forum français de la jeunesse
le jeune a entre 15 et 35 ans 35 ans
selon un sondage ipsos 63% des français
le voient comme égoïste et 53 % comme
paresseux il ya déjà de quoi se sentir
valorisé n'est ce pas pourtant autour de
moi je vois des jeunes qui change de
cerveau trois fois par jour pour être
successivement étudiants stagiaires
serveurs je vois des bac + 5 7 8
distribué des tracts publicitaires ou
livrer des plats à domicile
je veux aussi ceux qui entreprennent
créer leur propre métier ne se paye
jamais et retourne vivre chez leurs
parents à 30 ans pour garder leur
entreprise à flot
et puis ces autres à qui l'on dit qu'ils
n'ont pas assez d'expérience pour un
simple cdd et qui enchaîne les stages à
500 euros par mois cela pourtant même
qui avaient scrupuleusement suivi les
conseils prodigués pour réussir mais
c'est normal tu es jeune
ce qui est normal n'est pas forcément
acceptable
notre âge est bien trop souvent une
excuse une explication soit disant
logique aux obstacles qui pourtant
pourraient être évités alors comme j'ai
moins de 35 ans
et que je vis aujourd'hui en france j'ai
deux trois idées sur le sujet et même si
je ne suis représentatif de rien même si
plusieurs jeunesse coexistent au sein de
ma génération j'ai eu l'occasion de
raconter ce quotidien dans un livre dans
ce livre il fallait bien sûr parler de
la crise de la précarité du chômage
mais si on en reste là on a juste envie
de se pendre avec son chargeur d'iphone
j'avais aussi envie de parler de ce que
nous voyons de l'amour souvent virtuel
et de la politique toujours décevante
parlé également de notre appréhension de
l'argent qu'on a plutôt du mal à
appréhender
d'ailleurs mais aussi de ceux de cette
vision que nous avons de la famille et
de l'avenir cette vision qui dans les
deux cas restent floues mais surtout
surtout je tenais à décrire cette
mobilisation quasi-permanente
d'individus productive créatif et
résilients décrire également les
stratégies que nous mettions en place
pour croire encore que notre vie peut
être belle
et puis traduire l'épuisement d'une
génération
pourtant aux prémices de sa vie parce
que fait incroyable le jeune aussi peut
être fatiguée parce que ma génération
est présente dans toutes les couches de
la société
nous sommes dans les entreprises dans
les écoles dans les commerces à domicile
notre génération est une classe sociale
à part entière est essentielle au bon
fonctionnement de ce pays
imaginez quelques instants une france
sans jeunes plus personne pour servir
dans les fast-foods plus de baby sitter
plus d'hôtesses d'accueil plus de
stagiaires plus de stagiaires
si seulement la société nous faisait
sentir la confiance qu'elles en ont si
seulement nous étions considérés comme
ce que nous sommes
le futur ma génération est née au
commencement d'une société nouvelle
à 11 ans par exemple je téléchargeais
pour la première fois le single delory
oui c'est une erreur de jeunesse comme
une autre me direz vous mais internet
est arrivé dans nos vies et dès lors
tout a changé
on sait tout tout de suite on apprend
même à penser comme les fenêtres qui
s'ouvrent et se ferment sur nos écrans
nous sommes sept générations nouvelles
nous avons appris tout cela ce qu'il
faut savoir ce qui est vraiment très
intéressant de prendre en compte c'est
que bien souvent bien sûr on m'a dit que
il ya toujours eu un fossé entre les
générations que avant aussi c'était
compliqué mais ce n'est pas mieux ou
moins bien qu'avant c'est juste
différent
je sais très bien que le fossé est le
plat principal le principe des
générations d'ailleurs j'ai vite compris
que lorsque l'on parlait à nos parents
de notre réalité de notre quotidien
il pensait alors jeunesse c'est normal
c'est leur cadre de référence quand je
demandais à mon père ce qu'il faisait
comme petits boulots à 22 ans il m'a
répondu qu'il vendait des beignets sur
la plage pour se payer le concert de
david bowie le jour où je travaille pour
me payer un concert et non pour payer
mon loyer
c'est vraiment que j'ai réussi ma vie et
même même quand je parle avec ma mère je
me rends compte que j'ai mis du temps à
lui apprendre des choses qui pour moi
sont complètement intuitive la
synchronisation d'un smartphone la
dépasse complètement
et puis le loup bien sûr que je sais ce
que c'est qu'un contrôle c'est alors oui
mais si tu ne sais pas ce que c'est
qu'un contrôle v qu'est ce que tu fais
de ton contrôle c certaines choses ne
rentrent pas dans son système
et encore je ne vous parle pas du jour
où elle m'a demandé ce que voulait dire
inférieure à 3 à la fin de mon texto
pourtant ce qui semble nous éloigner
peut aussi nous rapprocher parce que au
delà de nos différences nous vivons bel
et bien dans le même monde et pour nous
tous ce monde
il commence à l'école justement nous ne
pouvons plus à prendre comme il ya
trente ou cinquante ans pourquoi écouter
un moustachu à lunettes
quand tout le savoir se trouve dans
notre poche il faut changer de véhicule
pour nous atteindre
sans quoi les jeunes iront plus à
l'école dans l' envie d'apprendre
mais dans l'obligation de s'y ennuyer et
dans mon idée on garde le moustachu et
lunettes il faut juste qu'ils prennent
en compte ce que nous sommes devenus des
êtres conscients multitâche ouvert sur
le monde et désireux d'élargir le champ
des possibles il serait également
intéressant d'encourager la transmission
à double sens
mes parents comme mes professeurs ont
l'expérience d'un monde qu'il est
important de connaître pour comprendre
comment et pourquoi le mien est apparu
or nous pouvons vous transmettre ce qui
fait partie de notre adn vous apprendre
ne veut pas dire rendre obsolète la
génération précédente
au contraire c'est un peu la même
philosophie de la permaculture
finalement chacun est utile à l'autre
tous ont plusieurs fonctions le basilic
vous tranquillement car il est protégé
du soleil par les tomates qui elles
mêmes sont embrasés grâce à la vigne et
entreprises c'est pareil jacqueline qui
arrivait en 82 dans les bureaux maîtrise
comme personne le fonctionnement de sa
boîte
par contre community manager pour elle
c'est du chinois et non de l'anglais
alors quand nos amis jeunes diplômés
arrivent pour son premier poste
elle qui ne connaît en rien le
merveilleux monde de l'entreprise
qu'elle a été formé à l'université et
bien
eh bien nous et demi a tout à apprendre
de jacqueline et jacqueline pourra plus
facilement se mettre aux chinois en fait
nous ne cherchons pas à vous remplacer
mais juste à trouver notre place nous
avons besoin de vous pour faire évoluer
un monde qui ne vous a pas forcément
rendu heureux ma génération tente juste
de se construire un avenir différent du
présent qui est le vôtre et certains
comme ceux qui vont s'adresser à vous ce
soir
certains ont choisi de résister résister
à l'absence de rêve et surtout ne rien
lâcher
finalement n'est ce pas ce que vous nous
souhaiter